in the past 20 years Israel has
controlled who goes in who goes out of
Gaza it controls what goes in what goes
out of Gaza about half the population
over the past 20 years has suffered from
what the international humanitarian
organizations call extreme food
insecurity about half the population of
Gaza is unemployed among youth it's
about 60% it has the highest
unemployment rate of any area in the
world half the population of Gaza
comprises children so when you hear
about Gaza you have to bear in mind of
those 2.3 million people living in Gaza
half are children 70% are refugees from
the first Arab Israeli War and the
descendants of refugees